without your phone or really any gadget
and flip it over and read the tiny text
on the back it probably says something
like made in China but you probably
already knew that huge Chinese factories
like Foxconn make all your iPhones and
all your Playstations but just like the
US has Apple and Microsoft China has its
big tech companies too you should get to
know them because they're starting to
take over the world
there's Huawei for instance it's already
one of the world's biggest smartphone
manufacturers and with a sub brand named
honor and a new phone called the honor
6x it's trying to make big inroads in
the States and you know what the phone's
pretty great and seriously cheap that's
one of the big advantages these Chinese
companies have because they're right
next door to their factories like
literally right next door sometimes that
means they can make more things more
quickly for less money that lets these
companies make anything and everything
you may not have heard of leh echo but
it sells TVs headphones VR headsets
smart bikes and a Netflix competitor all
under one roof G technology another name
you're going to start seeing here soon
isn't even three years old and it's
already building GoPro competitors
drones home security stuff and super
high-end mirrorless cameras and don't
roll your eyes
these things aren't knockoffs in many
cases they're actually better than their
bigger name competitors and they're
always cheaper the Chinese tech industry
has made an enormous effort over the
last few years to go from copycat to
innovator it's working every messaging
company in America is trying to copy
WeChat ability to be everything to
everyone
DJI is absolutely dominating the drone
industry you definitely know the Novo
and you've probably seen TCL's awesome
new TVs the list is just huge and
there's another company called Xiaomi
that looks like it's set to be the next
big one Xiaomi started by making cheap
great smartphones then it built a big
online store selling cases and fitness
trackers to go with your phone now it's
like a mix between Apple Amazon and a VC
firm Xiaomi invests in smaller companies
helping them with manufacturing and
marketing so that they can get their
idea mass-produced then they sell it in
the me store which has become one of the
biggest online shopping destinations in
the world
after dominating in China these
companies have now set their sights on
the US and they are going to shake up
the gadget industry they're going to
make fine tech online more popular than
ever they're going to prove once and for
all that we've been paying too much for
gadgets this whole time and next time
you need to upgrade you are going to be
absolutely spoiled for choice so no
matter what Trump might say made in
China is by no means
I think past